foreign
[Music]
that is quite a handful mouthful of a
name and let's see if we finally get
another
Main Line accelerated Dragon not fight
six and C3 so we're again we're facing
the elephant and this is very
interesting we're facing a version of
the elephant that does not allow us to
play the line that I recommended so the
line that I recommended has a bit of a
flaw you might remember that in response
to the standard alopin I recommend it D5
e takes D5 and then Knight F6 obviously
with a knight already on C6 if we play
D5 then we kind of have to recapture
with the queen so it's just that this
particular version of the elephant is
rare most people play it straight away
so here we're gonna have to play a
different line we're gonna have to play
either Knight F6 E5 Knight to D5 or
we're gonna have to play D5 and get into
that main line
or we we can play the move E5 which I
know is a very interesting sideline it's
gained in popularity recently but the
only downside is that I don't know it
very well
um in terms of my own knowledge I know
Knight F6 a lot better than the move E5
and E5 white is better with best play
but it can be very hard to prove it if
you're not super well versed in elephant
Theory let's risk it let's see what
happens let's go E5 I'm just interested
in my ability to improvise let's see if
we can out Fox our opponent in territory
that will hopefully be new to both of us
so E5 is a very risky move conceptually
for two reasons first of all and mainly
it creates a big hole on D5 but in many
Sicilian lines we like to arrange our
pawns on C5 and E5 the whole on D5 is
really not the end of the universe
because that's Square can be pretty
effectively protected by a bunch of the
minor pieces in the night off by the way
you also see black play E5 and weaken
that square and live to tell the tale D4
is one of White's two main moves the
other one is Bishop F1 to C4 kind of
playing this Italian style here white
strikes at the center this is the main
line and this leads by force to a kind
of mass trade in the center we we could
play D6 here but that affords white the
option of forcing an end game that's
really undesirable for black so we kind
of have no choice we play CD CD we play
Ed this is this is the theory that I
know
and the what I would compare this
position to is a scotch the only
difference being that the C pawns are
gone we literally have
a scotch opening like E4 E5 Knight F3
Knight C6 D4 Ed Knight D4
with the c pawns absent no question that
that favors white a little bit and the
reason that favors white is because this
D6 square is now quite a bit tender so
if we were to play Bishop to C5 which by
the way is what I like to play against
the standard Scotch white has the
additional move Knight to F5 and it
appears to me that the weakness of the
D6 Square might justify that line for
white
we might still have to play it but there
is a move which I like quite a bit more
which is Knight to F6 I think Knight F6
doesn't have the same problem
white has no time to play Knight F5 here
because the E4 Pawn is hanging
so we get kind of a scotch a slightly
worse version for black but this is very
much playable I think Knight C3
okay so now in the mainline four night
Scotch which we've kind of transposed to
Black's main move is Bishop to B4 I
think this move makes a lot of sense
here as well because we're trying to put
pressure on the E4 Pawn
there's also a very interesting move
Knight takes E4 which I'll talk a little
bit about after the game but I don't
want to risk it and I think we should
play straightforward chess here let's
start with Bishop B4 and then we'll
check the theory after the game
yeah white has to prove the advantage
here because we're treating this like a
four night Scotch which incidentally is
my recommendation for white
and if we were to add the C pawns
White's main move as Knight takes Knight
Pawn takes Knight and then the Bishop
from F1 comes out typically in this line
to D3 in order to support the E4 Pawn
because the pawn needs another supporter
we're threatening Knight takes E4
that's why we
that's why we bring our Bishop out
specifically to B4
in this line note that white can't play
Bishop D3 immediately because that would
drop the Knight on D4 very common
blunder people forget to take the Knight
first
and I think our opponent is finally on
his own we've done a good job of
improvising I think Bishop to G5 ooh
this this looks very dubious to me I
just when I see this move it's hard for
me to verbalize it right out off the bat
but there's just something about this
move which looks unsustainable to me and
what it really is is the fact that the
bishop on G5 is undefended and the fact
that White's not really addressing the
pin against the Knight these types of
indirect defensive moves are always very
risky for many reasons so one thing that
we could do I think the most
straightforward way to treat this
position with black is to play the move
H6 and Chase the bishop away the point
is if black if white drops back to H4
then we can play G5 Force the bishop to
G3 and then we play Knight takes C4 and
we win the pawn
if after H6 white takes the Knight then
we take back with the queen not only do
we attack the D4 Knight but we bag we
bag the bishop pair which is a great
thing in a wide open position but there
is another move that my attention is
drawn to and that's Queen d8 to A5 and
you get this type of Queen sortsi pretty
often you wouldn't get it by the way
with the addition of the Pawn on C7 so
that's an additional resource that we
get because there's no Pawn on C7 didn't
think it would be a good thing what does
Queen A5 do well Queen A5 is just a
double attack it hits the bishop and
we're threatening Bishop takes Knight
check
and that's a problematic situation for
white because white doesn't have time to
come back to D2 with his Bishop then
white drops the Knight on D4
so after Queen A5 white might have to
play Knight takes C6
in that position we could take the
Knight with check but I don't love that
option so probably we would take the
Knight back with BC and then white could
wiggle out by dropping the bishop back
to D2 not a great position for white but
it's not like winning for black either
I think we'll play it simple and we'll
go with H6 let's see what our opponent
has cooked up here I'm just curious
because H6 is like the in your face move
yeah our opponent gives away the bishop
air already a very nice position for
black 9 Moves In
and problems for white concretely
because he's just not developed and the
king is stuck in the center so white has
to tread very carefully to avoid further
material losses
and you could lose this game in like
three moves easily
Knight DB5
so I'll put it this way in this position
there is an adventurous move that sadly
doesn't work it almost works but it
doesn't
so what do I see when I look at this
position well the first thing I notice
is that if we could would remove this
knight from B5 we would have Bishop
takes Knight check and then Queen takes
Pawn check and that's awesome because
white can essentially never block with
Queen D2 because the Rook on A1 hangs
but we can force White's King to E2
that's a huge thing so the move A6 comes
to mind a lot of people would reject A6
because of Knight C7 check but in and of
itself the fork is not dangerous Knight
C7 check King d8 and if white plays
Knight takes A8 then we play Bishop
takes C3 check we recapture with the
queen and if the King goes up to E2 we
can actually win White's Queen by giving
a check on D4 with the Knight Knight D4
check the King on E2 is checkmated so
white has to give up the queen for the
night here's the problem this is hard to
see after A6 Knight C7 check King to d8
who can tell me
what White's best move is in that
position not easy at all because your
eyes are fixated on the rook in the
corner it's hard to come up with this
move
Knight back to D5 yeah Knight C7 back to
D5 that hits the queen it centralizes
the Knight but mainly
it defends the Knight on C3 so A6
actually is a mistake
if Asics is a mistake that basically
means we have only one feasible move
other than A6 which is to Castle just to
get the king out of the center now A6
becomes a huge threat because Knight C7
is no longer a check and we would be
able to take the knight in the court so
here we have another dilemma A3 has been
played
the default move to me is Bishop A5
the other move is Bishop to C5 because
it threatens mate on F2 but I like
Bishop to A5 because we're inducing the
move before why is B4 something that's
good for us well because B4 makes the
Knight on C3 even weaker it also opens
up an x-ray between the black queen and
the white Rook on A1 which means at any
time white plays Knight to D5 in the
future chances are there might be a
tactic connected to white stroke in the
corner so Bishop A5 is Good from all
sides it keeps the pin on the Knight it
keeps the threat of A6 and if we can
force white to play the move before then
we've created even more weaknesses on
the queen side so we play this move
really without additional calculation we
just
we use comparison to determine that A5
is the best Square for the bishop yeah
after B4 a lot of you are noticing
Knight takes before I'm not sure we want
to sack the Knight there I don't think
that was a good idea we'll talk about it
after the game okay so we can take this
game in a lot of different directions
this is a pretty exciting position we
have a lot of tactical potential in our
position
so I would divide moves in this position
into like a simple category and then
more tactically oriented moves that have
to be calculated there is a move here
that I'm drawn to which is highly
tactical it's them of d75 sacrificing
the pawn in order to quickly open up the
rest of our pieces so D5 is a move that
we come up with intuitively but there
are also simpler moves A6 is tempting
but probably white is going to stick the
Knight on D6 as a response okay and what
was the point of Rook C1 it was to
reinforce the Knight on C3 was a great
move so after A6 Knight D6 we could play
a move like Knight C6 to D4 probably
we're gonna trade on C8 and black is
maybe a little bit better is there
anything with more meat on the bone well
it's hard to say the move Rook to E8
also came to my mind it's on my radar
because it hits the pawn on e4 Rook
takes E4 it becomes a threat because the
Knight on C3 is spinned so Rook E8 is
another good move I like A6 I think A6
might be the simplest approach to this
position
D5 I'm not sure there's a follow-up
after e takes D5
it's tempting then to deliver a check
but white blocks the check with Bishop
E2 and white is ready to Castle in the
resulting position and once White
Castles that's it our attack in the
center evaporates
D5 is a little too crazy we'll explore
it a little bit more after the game
but I really like the look of rookie 8.
I like the look of rookie 8 because
we're also tempting white into playing
what what I think would be a serious
mistake Bishop to D3 this is like such a
common move at all levels because it's a
reactive move and what people forget to
do is when we discuss a developing move
people forget to check the drawbacks of
such a move and boy could it have some
drawbacks B4 is what our opponent plays
without further Ado let's drop our
Bishop back to B6 the sack on B4 would
be bad because even after we take on
before congrats you still have the pin
on the night but you're not threatening
the Knight on C3 so white has that Tempo
that he could use to play Queen D4 maybe
it would have been interesting but I
that's not the kind of Chess that we're
trying to play on the speed run we're
trying to play first and foremost our
Allegiance is to like fundamentally
sound chess
so if we allow white to Castle here this
is what makes this such an exciting
position right if white could play
Bishop E2 in Castle's King side from a
positional standpoint we are worse and
largely the absence of the C7 Pawn you
can see how it makes us pay positionally
right look at these weak squares D6 and
D5 these are outposts for white both of
White's Knights so we can't allow white
to consolidate and start occupying these
apples we need to keep pounding at him
while he hasn't castled yet so Rook 2 C2
all right
so
this is really interesting we have a lot
of promising I don't think Rook C2 was a
particularly good move
so Asics again he wants Knight D6 and
then some of you might see Bishop takes
F2 check okay that's a tactic Rook F2
Queen F6 takes C3 check white will
probably block with the queen and we get
an end game up a pawn okay that's an
option but I don't like allowing the
Knight onto D6
what else do we have well we can still
play the move D5 which I'm really
attracted to because Knight takes D5
doesn't work we take on e4 with check
and then we can actually take on F2 on
the next move and what I also like about
the move D5 is that the e-pawn is now
pinned so if white wants to take the
Bonnie has to take over this queen and
that then allows us to develop with
Tempo I'm gonna make this move
essentially on the basis of intuition
alone because this is what people don't
really understand about Pawn sacrifices
it's not such a big investment even if
white collects the pawn which he can
only do with a queen and magically
consolidates white develops the bishop
in castles with the wide open Center you
know for a fact that you're gonna have
great compensation even if White Castles
so it's not such a big risk to give up a
pawn in a middle game most games are
decided by a much bigger margin than an
extra Pawn at a GM level yes but I level
that of the people who are watching
you know Sac pawns if you think it's
good if you think it gives you piece
activity you should err on the side of
taking the risk
the threshold I think is a minor piece
if you're sacking a minor piece that is
the tendency to that is the potential to
decide the game if it doesn't work out
so you generally need to calculate much
more concretely than when you sack a
pawn
yeah people of that sort you know weak
players that
as usual
and again I don't I in all seriousness I
obviously don't mean this kind of
soundingly I just mean this
realistically right you you know not
everything is the same at all levels in
chess and you know you have to tailor
your play to where you're at
okay Bishop to D3 so our opponent
desperately trying to defend the E4 upon
but this is a lost cause because as long
as we keep the pin on the e-file D takes
E4 is begging to be played because after
white recaptures the Knight or or the
bishop to just get into the frying pan
there must be something in that
resulting position there must be
now A6 here traps the Knight on B5 but
notice that white has Knight takes D5 as
a result and even in that position we
can play Queen G5 and G2 is hanging but
that gets messy let's start by taking on
e4 then we need to invest some time and
see if we can figure out a winning move
after Knight takes E4 because white is
now one move away from castling which
means that we need to strike now or
forever hold our piece okay let's think
let me think about this for a second
there are several like interesting moves
I'm just trying to find the best one
okay I think I found it I think I
figured out what to do and I think the
simplest move is the best one here yeah
Bishop F5 is it's what everybody's
suggesting
but it this is not an automatic move and
I'll explain why it took me a second to
refute rookie to rookie two fails to a
very pretty tactic
you should notice right right off the
bat that the F2 square is a problem
Square for white I don't care that
there's a pawn there so after rookie two
we just play Bishop takes Bishop takes
Rook takes deflection Rook takes Queen
takes F2 mate
that means white basically has to play
Pawn F3 and the great thing about
inducing Pawn F3 is that white can no
longer Castle because the bishop on V6
is controlling G1 so then we can finally
breathe a little bit easier and we can
play quote-unquote Slow moves to
accumulate the pressure we don't even
have to think in that case about going
directly for the kill although we should
look for winning tactics if they exist
so what would be an example of a quote
unquote slow move that we could play
after F3
what's a move that just sort of like
improves our position and creates more
potential long-term threats yeah just
Rook a to d8 which should be automatic
to you I've talked about this often
moves like Rook a to d8 are incredibly
powerful if you have the time to play
them how do we know we have the time to
play them well we know that after F3
white is no longer close to castling you
understand the logic should make sense
now Rook 88 is far from the only move
you can play A6 there and Chase the
Knight away and then stick your own
Knight on D4 maybe you were attracted to
that possibility but I like I like
keeping this Knight on B5 because it's
super vulnerable and we can play A6
whenever we want to play it and it would
be winning Knight C3 okay
probably the best move
so what I'm saying is Queen to G6 that's
one option White Castles and then we
take a bunch of times on e4 and we have
two pieces for a rook which by the way
the last Speed Run game feature two
pieces for I'd like to avoid that if
possible there's a move that I like a
lot more there's a move that I like a
lot more than Queen G6 which actually is
Rook a to d8 and the idea is to pin the
queen and some people might refute this
move because you allow white to Castle
but even after White Castles we play
Bishop take C4 Knight takes E4 and of
course the idea is to play Rook take C4
Bishop E4 Rook takes Queen Rook takes
Rook black has a queen and a knight for
two Rooks which is an overwhelming
amount of material if you're newer to
chess queen versus two Rooks is
approximately equal material if you have
another minor piece on top of it you're
chilling you're you're totally good
you're totally chilling so we're just
accumulating right Rook 88 which is
a move we know is good
and if white plays rookie too we have a
beautiful tactic
let's see if he falls for it
I mean maybe the tactic doesn't work no
he castles okay so this we're gonna win
this in rather unglamorous style but
still
I think a game that illustrates
just how disastrous it could be to keep
your king in the center for too long
and then once and for all okay so Rook
takes E4 that's why we put the Rook on
d8 we were basically playing against
black White's Queen and against Dwight's
King at the same time that's why we put
the Rooks on the two open files
okay white has to take at this point
white has to give it a shot
but then we take
white takes we'll make a little bit of
Luft with a move like G6 so that there's
no back rank shenanigans
and then the
you know game should be a matter of
converting a big material advantage
this is this is game over
it all looks very simple when you play a
game like this but you could see that a
lot of thought actually went into
a lot of the moves in the middle game
okay B5
okay there's a thousand ways to play
here
the method we want to choose is one that
eliminates complexity and is very simple
so like what I mean by that is The Rook
on e4 is still a hanging piece if
possible we'd like to avoid moves that
exacerbate the complexity is there a way
to move this stroke away from the
vulnerable Square there is the move 95
95 is a great move Bishop E4 Rook D1 but
there's another great move which is even
simpler which is to play Rook E4 to D4
Rook ed4 right we're counter-attacking
the bishop there's an important line
there actually so let's play rookie D4
BC Rook takes D3 white can play them
with C7 that can look scary but we can
just take White's Queen because if white
takes our rook and makes a new Queen we
have three pieces that can recapture on
d8
so Rook D4 is simple BC Rook takes D3
you solidify the extra piece and then on
the next move
you can play B takes C6 there's actually
a crazy idea that white has here which I
didn't see
and the idea is Queen takes D3 Rook
takes D3 and C takes B7 and white is
threatening to promote the pawn and
white has this move Rook to C8 to assist
in the Pawn's promotion but black has
several ways to win in that position I'm
pretty sure we'll cross that bridge if
we when we get there actually that's a
very very problematic idea very
problematic idea
no we have a beautiful wind there
actually I really am hoping he plays it
because we have a beautiful winning idea
in that position beautiful
come on I I actually really hope people
this is one of the cases where I'm
hoping that he makes the quote-unquote
best move
how do you see a move like Queen takes
you well it's the rule anytime there's a
pass spawn on the sixth rank or on the
seventh rank in the middle game and get
his amount you have to look at tactics
that basically involve whether they
involve clearing the way
for clearing the way for the fun we're
gonna likely have the same tactic after
our opponent plays Rook take C6 the same
tactic that we would have used
to win the game after Queen takes D3 we
have now can anybody see it this is a
classic puzzle Rush pattern everybody
should know this pattern this happens in
puzzle Rush all the time Queen takes F2
unfortunately it's not made like white
can play King H1 here technically but
the point of course is Rook after Rook
D1 is made Queen takes D1 or D1 is made
because the Rook is automatically pinned
when it captures the queen
so what you need for this kind of tactic
is access to the back Rank and then a
Queen Bishop battery against the F fun
you play to deflect the rook and The
Rook occupies the role of a third Pawn
on F2 it's it's pinned so it's like a
pawn
yeah this is nice but okay now we can
continue the pretty play we can simplify
into an end game this is another pattern
that you should all be familiar with
anytime you have access to the back rank
you have access also to simplifying
combinations right tactics that are not
aimed at checkmating your opponent but
are aimed at forcing a bunch of trades
no don't play Rook D1 here because white
has two Defenders on that square
first well Queen E2 is the move I would
plan actually Queen E2 might be winning
on the spot let me think
yeah yeah I'm gonna amend
yeah but Queenie two white is Queenie
one what I'm talking about is Queen take
let's play this move just to illustrate
the concept Queen takes F1 very simple
white takes back and then you re-pin the
queen with Rook to D1
you re-pin the queen with the Rook to D1
and incidentally this is almost
Checkmate like white can't take white
does have the move technically Rook to
C1 okay but the game is over we're up a
freaking piece
so the simplest way there's two main
ways to win a position like this the
first is to trade Rooks and trading
Rooks will leave us with only a bishop
that'll make it really easy the second
way is just to go after
White's remaining pawns and the pawn
that you should really try to go after
is A3
and then combining the two ideas often
yields very quick Victory so the first
move okay would be Rook D3
white would have to choose between A4
and Rook A1 if A4 then Rook A3 picks up
the pawn if Rook A1 then you dislodge
The Rook with Bishop D4 you win the pawn
and then incidentally white can't stop
the move Rook A1 which would trade Rooks
okay
so no not rematch
let's have a look at first and foremost
the opening Theory but before we do that
I want to mention in the end what would
have happened after Queen D3 Rook D3 CB
so there's multiple ways to win here
there's multiple ways to win
but the the prettiest is this move Queen
F4
which is a move that you should see I
mean that stops the pawn but it also
looks like it doesn't work because of
course white has this check
and after King H7 why it promotes but if
you're familiar with the tactic here
black has Queen F2
and in contrast to the game continuation
The Rook on F1 is undefended so King H1
is futile Rook F2 Rook D1 is also
checkmate
but there's a Twist in this position
white has an attempt to improve on this
line
rather than playing rixian immediately
white can throw in the Intermezzo G3
now what does G3 do well what G3 does is
it eliminates the mechanism right if the
queen stays on this diagonal after Rook
C white black is still winning with Rook
d8 by the way but now you don't have
this queen takes F2 combination but
rather than playing Queen E5 black has
another beautiful idea which is another
idea that you should be familiar with
when you're pinning the F Pawn it's Rook
takes G3 The Rook yes hg3 Queen G3 using
the pin on the F Bond the poor F Pawn
and now you use the exposed nature of
the king to Simply pick up the pawn
that's the easiest way to win and you're
overwhelmingly up material
so some very very nice details here
that would have been the best way to win
incidentally you can also start with the
Rook d8 you can also do this and you can
also win like this King H7
this is also winning because again if
white promotes then Queen takes F2 is
mate if white takes the Rook then you
take back and here it's easy to surround
and win the pawn
and if white plays some move like G3 in
order to try to prevent
Queen takes F2 then believe it or not
the engine move is Rook D2 this is like
typical engine play because the engine
allows you to promote because it's
calculated until Checkmate humans don't
play like that here King H1 Queen F3 is
mate and if the king steps into the line
of fire of The Rook then you just drop
the bishop back Force the king out you
take on F1 and this is obviously going
to be Checkmate in just a couple moves
yeah no very very complicated lines
actually but let's rewind let's start
from the start because we faced this
line we decided to play E5
I'm gonna check what the elephant Bible
recommends here for white because if
we're already looking at this we might
as well look at this from White's point
of view and fill ourselves in on what to
do against this line from the white side
because I also recommend the elephant
and I don't remember very well
so let's look
so of course the authors of the book
they analyze it through a different move
order
but we're lucky because they analyze it
through this move order but their
recommendation is in fact to play Knight
F3 so we get the same position
as through this move order okay their
move is in fact
Bishop C4 aha so they recommend Bishop
C4
and they say white will hardly obtain an
advantage after D4 they call this move a
mistake
takes because of takes takes takes
Knight F6 Knight C3 but should be four
so they give this line and they say
white is not better here wow that's
really good to know white is not worse
either here our opponent made the
mistake of playing Bishop G5
but
apparently D4 does not yield an
advantage you're supposed to play Bishop
C4
so most people in this position they
play Knight F6 the vast majority of
people playing Knight F6 and now we play
Let's see what we play we play Knight G5
we play this like a fried liver
D5 ed5
Knight D5
so if in this position black plays
Knight A5 the difference between this
and the fried liver is that in the fried
liver you might know that black has the
move C6 here black doesn't have that
move black has to cover with a bishop
and apparently you have this very
powerful move Queen to A4
A6
following
Bishop B7 Bishop D7 Knight D7 96x Glam
black would end up in a very difficult
position f-e-d-e and you win the night
back with interest
castles Ed White is up two Pawns
Knight C6 will have Queen G4 defending
the pawn from the other side
and then you focus on bringing your
pieces out with D3
Rook G6 Queen chills out on H3 Rook D6
and now you bring your pieces out Bishop
E3 Rook takes D3
check
so black actually ends up winning both
of the pawns back but at the end of the
day white gets a much better end game
because black has terrible pawns and
white has a great Square for the Knight
they give plus over minus here
followed by 94 Black's bad Bishop on E7
makes his defense in this ending in very
difficult yeah also this bishop is bad
so that's the line they give there
If instead
after Queen A4 black plays A6
immediately then you play Bishop D7
Knight D7 you played T3 so that the
Knight is protected
B5 Queen essentialized
C4 okay and D6 interesting move white
frees the D5 Square for his Queen
it is also possible for him to continue
D4 but whatever let's follow the main
recommendation if ah there's Queen D5
here it's a great idea Checkmate Bishop
Rook so black can't defend everything at
the same time
yeah D6 is super strong so the engine
move here is Rogue B8 Queen D5 anyway
Queen F6
B4 forcing the Knight back
Knight B6 wow D7 check deflecting the
Knight
E7 I mean back Knight back Bishop out
plus minus obviously the king is
terrible here
so
Knight F6 Knight G5 D5 Ed Knight A5
Bishop B5 and queen A4 now this is the
move that I I faced this online
ah so now you're not supposed to play
this in the fried liver this is the
common trap here black is actually
better
so you're not supposed to do this
instead you're supposed to play this
move
so you provoke G6 and now you drop back
to F3
Queen takes G5 is forced
If instead Bishop E6 then you just take
the bishop and Black's Pawn structure
sucks
Bishop takes D5 attacking F7 Knight d8
and now we Castle
and now you're threatening to play D4
and open up a discovery against black
screen so their main move is Queen E7
after Queen F5
white can maintain an edge in the end
game as well as by avoiding the exchange
of the queens and entering a middle game
so they recommend rookie one
Bishop G7 D4 with an advantage obviously
white is better here black is super
cramped and he's losing some Pawns
so Queen E7 is their main move rookie
won anyway x-raying the queen okay
Bishop G7 D4 with a big initiative CD CD
and black is under tremendous fire here
if castles I think you just play d e and
here you have Bishop F4 winning the
bishop because black can't play F6
yeah so
that makes sense that makes sense so
basically
if white black plays D5 and Knight takes
D5 you play Queen H5 to induce this
weakness you drop the queen back
if Queen F5 in this position then you
win with Bishop takes C6 and you win The
Rook so black has to play Knight d8
then New Castle to threaten D4
and you put the Rook on E1 basically
regardless of what black does unless
black doesn't move the queen then you
open up a discovery against the queen
you see this is how opening learning
works it's not a mysterious process this
is why books are so good because you
check it immediately you you memorize it
boom that's it we'll never have a
problem against D5 ever again so people
they mythologize the process of learning
openings when in fact it's just about
getting your hands dirty and rolling up
your sleeves and just like processing
what's written in a book or written in
an adjustable course that's all there is
to it
so in the game our opponent played an
inferior move d4 is wrong because we get
basically a four night Scotch we
basically get a four night Scotch
without the C7 and C2 pawns which
shouldn't really all that much change
the evaluation of the position but
Bishop G5 is a very serious mistake the
correct move here is in fact to play
this like a regular Scotch Bishop D3 we
would have castled or we would have
played something like D5 Pawn takes D5
and we get sort of a classic situation
apparently there's a nice little check
on E7 that you can throw in to basically
Force the end game
because in this position if white blocks
with a bishop then you play Knight takes
D5 and this is quite unpleasant you're
attacking a bunch of stuff here so Queen
E2
and apparently Knight takes D5 is best
with something resemble
maybe like a micron better for white
here because of the slightly deficient
Pawn structure but black is fine in this
position it's very solid
I think white is
a smidge a smidge better
a smidge better in this line but we
would have played this we would have
played D5 also black and Castle here
probably first and then play D5 I
wouldn't play D6 here because then the
bishop comes out of this pin is really
nasty usually you want to play D5 in the
fortnite scotch if you're black and here
also e takes D5 this I would I would
want to avoid with black because this is
an iqp
and here it looks like white is quite a
bit better
maybe this is also a decent way to play
this line but Bishop G5 is bad for many
reasons
one of them is that we can just play H6
and hopefully it made sense to you guys
why Bishop H4 is bad because here G5
Bishop G3 is this is a very
straightforward line and white is in
trouble obviously
we could have also played Queen A5 the
engine likes Queen A5
and the basic idea of Queen A5
is that if white plays Bishop takes F6
you don't just meekly take back you take
on C3 twice
and this is a very scary scenario
because
you're attacking The Rook so white can't
play Queen D2 white has to go King E2 I
wasn't sure how to evaluate this
position I think I even talked about
this during the game I just didn't know
what the evaluation here was apparently
it's minus plus black is much better
notice that black screen drops back in
defends the the C7 Square
so white can deliver a check but the
King goes up and Y can deliver another
check but the King goes down the king
escapes the checks actually no this is
wrong because of Queen D6 you're
supposed to go
you're supposed to go King D so that so
that this move is in a check
so white has to waste the tempo and now
you open up the center with D5
and if Queen takes D5
you liquidate blah blah blah you take
everything and black is up a full Pawn
in the ensuing end game so this would
have offered winning chances as well but
I'm happy with a I think H6 is simpler
because it gives us the bishop pair and
it gives us a huge initiative the engine
is always good in such positions but
it's very very hard for a human to play
something like this so we castle and our
opponent plays A3 which I think is a
good move Bishop A5
and I think Rook C1 is a big mistake I
think it's just too slow I think Rook C1
is too slow
um because here we start accumulating a
massive initiative
and I'm not saying rookie 8 is correct I
just feel like Rick C1 is a mistake
according to the engine
the best approach here either after
before or before before you can start
with before
and apparently this is the only move
Queen to F3
offering the queen trade that's how you
douse the Flames of the initiative and
if black wastes a Tempo declining the
trade then white can use that Tempo to
entrench a knight on the in the center
and now rookie 8 is less effective
because white develops very quickly
Bishop B2
white simply gives up the E4 pawn and
then castles again Pawn sacrifices are
super common here black is in trouble
because black is paralyzed and Bishop D3
is threatened and black can't even do
this because of the fork on E7
so this is a very problematic situation
probably we would have taken the queen
and done something like Knight to D4 to
get rid of White's best Knight on B5 and
black is still a little bit better here
I I would prefer black here
but obviously this is a better version
than what happened in the game
yeah Queen F3 for some reason is a hard
move to find is it's just not intuitive
to go into an end game like that but
definitely Rook C1 was very slow I
understand why our opponent played it so
now we're key
so we reincrea increase the pressure on
e4 according to the computer apparently
D5 immediately was very very strong here
I thought about this I didn't see a
follow-up to Ed
but here apparently black is winning
with the move Bishop B6
threatening Checkmate so let's say white
defense now it's minus ah now rookie a
check and white can't block on E2
if white plays F3 then I think it's
obvious why this is horrible for white
is white will never be able to Castle
this is awful and if white plays like
this black has this move Queen G5
hitting the Rook on C1 so that's another
bad reason reason that Rook C1 was
better Rook actually can be targeted
Queen G5 is
a ridiculously hard move to understand
like why it's good because it hits the
Rook if the Rook goes here then you pin
The Rook if the Rook goes the other way
well black just gets a Monumental
initiative here the knights coming to G4
and
the e-file is open and this is just a
disaster for white this that you should
understand why by this position is
winning for black without calculation
like you should look at this and say
yeah I understand whites King is busted
here this kind of intuition is very
important like roughly evaluate these
types of positions
okay so instead we played rookie 8
before Bishop B6 and apparently still ah
now Queen F3 still should have been
played yeah I still think our opponent
should have played this although here
there's already Queen G5 hitting the
Rook now this is an inferior version
according to the computer F3 was the
preferable move but you know try playing
this position Jesus
or try playing the position after just
the simple move like D6 just opening up
a diagonal for the light skirt Bishop
there's Queen G5 and again black is
winning because white just gets screwed
on the dark squares absolutely screwed
on the dark squares
um but roxy2 loses after D5 white is
busted white is completely and utterly
and totally busted because he's not
close to castling and we're already
massacring him in the center I would
play Queen E5 here with white I think
it's the only chance so once again
Knight T5 Rook E4 is just game over
because white loses F2
Queen takes D5 the simplest move is
Bishop E6 the engine move is Rogue d8
hitting the queen that way
Queen is no good squares it has to like
retreat slink away
then black is winning here with many
different moves such as Bishop E6
also the engine likes Queen F4 for some
reason ah to stop Knight D5 so that you
take the pawn to the check white can't
move the bishop anywhere but C4 and ah
this is the idea oh my God Bishop F2
Rook F2 of course Queen C1 that's why we
played Queen F4 and now the bishop comes
out forcing The Rook up and now we take
this rook and then we'll take the other
one and we'll take G2 and it's totally
winning
wow Queen F4 what a move
yeah Queen F4 but not the only move you
can win like this too here it's just
that there's Knight D5 apparently this
move is now winning yeah these positions
are hard to play accurately but you can
kind of tell how overwhelming it is when
you see Black's pieces as active as they
are
which is why you play Such moves on
intuition so one of the big takeaways
from this game is like moves like D5 you
should be able to play without
calculating too much of course our
opponent played here and now very
important move is Bishop F5
and the idea was that rookie two
we just take twice we're trying to force
white to play F3 and if Whitehead played
F3 we would have brought the rook in and
I think the rest I'll leave to to the
viewer to figure out why this is totally
overwhelming this is minus eight because
white can't move
after an I see through Rook d8 Castle's
Bishop B4
there's nothing left to analyze
technically B5 is another mistake white
should take this would allow white to
prolong the game but this is still
completely and totally lost the knights
coming into the center the bishop and
the queen are permanently aimed at this
very weak pawn and this is just a matter
of relatively simple technique
of course B5 Rook d4b0x D3 ended the
game even faster the name of the book is
squeezing the Sicilian this is like what
I refer to as this allop and Bible
this is what I use for like all of my
official recommendations on the white
side that's cool we Face the elephant a
few times and I've shown you several
ways that you can challenge alopin
players practically because a lot of
people will go D4 and I think a lot of
people will get into trouble exactly the
same way that our opponent got into
trouble Knight C6 is not an intuitive
move because it helps black get more
Pawns in the center you have to know
that this is like the only way to keep
your Center intact okay so 55 you force
the bishop you give itself up for the
Knight you get the bishop pair we Castle
we play very patiently rookie eight
accumulate accumulate and then bang
blast open the center based on intuition
alone
and then attacking pawns and attacking
Queens not getting fixated on attacking
the king but understanding that there
are other things that you can exploit
while you're attacking big big thing
that people forget about they get
fixated on I have to check man I have to
Checkmate they forget that the actual
game-winning tactic could have nothing
to do with the weak King it could be
something else entirely such as an x-ray
or a pin against the queen we didn't win
this game by mating the king we won this
game by mating like the queen
okay I think that'll that'll be it for
today those two Speed Run games which is
basically unheard of in a six hour
stream
I think it's time for me to call it
um I want to thank everybody for
watching and for the energy unless
there's any more energy coming from the
chat
just kidding once again wanted to put in
one last shout out for the course I'll
be talking about it over the next few
days
the course is out you can find it at the
command X Glam course
you know it's uh a labor of love so so
far
we have sold
let me tell you how many people have
bought the course
124 people
about the course so
you can join that number we want to get
to
our goal before we release the course
was something like 5000. that's a very
ambitious course but if people like it
then hopefully we reach that number one
day
but we'll try we can get to 125 that's
for sure all right guys thank you so
much for watching see you guys later
thanks for hanging out I'll stream
tomorrow
hopefully
[Music]